Tyrion Lannister is one of the most
popular characters in Game of Thrones
and for good reason
Tyrion is funny and clever but also
flawed and pained he shows kindness to
the vulnerable and the back of his hand
[ __ ] like Joffrey he's at a pretty
rough time of it he's been falsely
accused of murder
imprisoned caught up in a war then
politics ended up in another battle had
his face cut off was forced into a
deeply uncomfortable marriage was
falsely accused of murder again betrayed
by his lover sentenced to death and
ended up killing his dad or was it his
dad officially Tyrion is the son of
Tywin Lannister and Tywin's cousin
Joanna but a controversial fan theory
claims that Tyrians real father is the
Mad King Aerys Targaryen so back in the
bad old days of the mad Kings reign the
Targaryen were in charge and young
Joanna a companion of Raiola Eris's
sister and a ventricle queen meanwhile
Tywin grew up frustrated with his father
Lord Titus who had a reputation for
weakness and was openly mocked to the
point that Tywin began to mistrust
laughter itself Tywin became determined
to be the powerful respected even feared
man that his father was not so he
slaughtered the rebellious topics and
the rains of castamere began restoring
the prestige and power of hustling astir
and was made hand of the king not long
after Tywin and Joanna were married
Tywin loved Joanna
apparently he smiled at their wedding
and Tywin doesn't smile much but
something else happened that night
according to sue Barristan who was
Kingsguard at the time King Aerys wanted
Joanna a few years at her wedding to
Tywin Aerys made a drunken joke they
implied that he wanted to sleep with her
and later he took liberties we don't
know exactly what those liberties were
it probably wasn't sex and it was too
early to have Vayne Tyrians conception
anyway but what this shows is that King
Aerys lusted for Tyrians mother and did
something to her on her wedding night in
a Storm of Swords Joffrey tells Sansa
that Kings often sleep with whoever they
want including married women so King
Aerys not only wanted Joanna he probably
could have had her Aerys Targaryen might
have fathered Tyrion
but just quickly it has been questioned
whether Johanna was even at King's
Landing with eros at the time of Tyrians
conception it seems likely that she was
because Tywin presumably would have been
there as hand of the king and Johanna
must have been with Tywin if not Eris 4
Tyrians conception that said Johanna was
apparently at Casterly Rock shortly
before giving birth to Tyrion she died
giving birth to Tyrion by the way so
it's unclear maybe Johanna was at King's
Landing with Eris and that's when Tyrion
was conceived or maybe Johanna was that
possibly rocked the whole time and it
couldn't have been Eris or for all we
know Eris could have father Tyrion out
possibly Rock basically it's
inconclusive and it may have been errors
so if it was Eris who fathered Tyrion
does Tywin know it's conceivable that
you never knew maybe Joanna was
threatened into keeping it secret and
Tywin's ignorance of Jaime and so she's
relationship shows that he's
impressively good at being ignorant of
the sexual proclivities of his loved
ones but it makes a lot of sense if
Taemin did know firstly because he
outright says it a couple of times and
also because it explains Tywin's hatred
for Tyrion this hatred is usually said
to be because Tyrion killed Joanna in
childbirth which is kind of a ridiculous
reason to hate the kid or he hates
Tyrion for making a mockery of House
Lannister by publicly drinking and
whoring even that is kind of hard to
believe Tywin has been an absolute
cafeteria and well before Tyrion was
drinking and whoring Tyrion was just 16
when Tywin refused to let him travel and
instead put him in charge of all the
drains and cisterns within costly rock
and just 13 when he had Tyrians love
Tasha raped by his guards like [ __ ] who
could do that to their own son Jaime and
Cersei have their personality defects
but Tywin doesn't do anything to them
nor without good reason anyway further
Tywin disowns Tyrion when Tywin is
obsessed with his legacy is it really
worse for him to have Tyrion is an heir
than no heir at all Tywin knowing or
suspecting Tyrion to be Eris's son makes
all of this makes sense
when Aerys made Jaime Kingsguard and
therefore ineligible to inherit Casterly
Rock
Eris made his bastard Tyrion the heir to
Taiwan's legacy that spits in the face
of everything Tywin works for so of
course Tywin disowns Tyrion of course he
treats the Mad King son like [ __ ] and of
course he sacks heiresses City shortly
after the thing with Jaime the real
question is why Tywin would allow Tyrion
to live as a Lannister at all maybe
because despite being the mad Kings
bastard despite being a dwarf Tyrion is
johannah's son
a Lannister and the son of the woman
Tywin loved more than anything it might
even be a promise me Tywin sort of a
situation so Tywin treats Tyrion pretty
abhorrently but still ensures he lives a
very comfortable life as a member of one
of the Great Houses funds him with
plenty of gold and only tries to have
him killed occasionally you know by
putting him on the front lines of this
battle for nuclear reason maybe Taemin
figured that way he could get rid of
Tyrion without directly Kingsland anyway
so here's the next piece of evidence
it's a common Targaryen trait to have
dreams of dragons often prophetic dreams
Daenerys Amon Darrin and daemon
Targaryen are all known to have dragon
dreams the other character who dreams of
dragons is tyrion tyrion is interesting
dragons though is clearly a different
thing to the dreams had by Danny and
others there's no evidence of Tyrion
having literal dreams about dragons at
all certainly nothing like this stuff
the likely explanation is that Tyrion
just liked dragons because dragons are
cool the reference to Tyrians dragon
dreams is maybe a hint but it's not a
strong one
so now Tyrians appearance tyrion has one
green eye and one black one and hair
that is both pale blonde and black
Lannister's are endlessly described as
having golden blond hair but the pale
blond of Tyrians hair seems more similar
to Targaryen hair which is generally
described as silver blond it might be
silly to pay this much attention to hair
color but as we were told in the first
book seed is strong and hair color can
tell a lot about someone's parentage
Tyrians pale blonde hair is more similar
to the Targaryen Civil War than
Lannister gold so that could be a hint
to his parentage
so tyrion also has mismatched eyes
there's another character with
mismatched eyes in the song shiera
seastar a bastard a fake on the fourth -
a garyun and like the two colored hair
the two colored eyes could symbolically
indicate Tyrians mixed blood maybe a
final note on his appearance it's been
suggested that Terrans dwarfism might be
the result of Targaryen genetic
weirdness or possibly the result of
attempted abortion donor how biology
works in the world of Ice and Fire but
we have no precedent for either of those
things occurring so they don't seem
strong bases of evidence
a final hint and possibly a big one if
Tyrion is a Targaryen he could fit very
nicely into the prophecy of the three
heads of the Dragon
Tyrion Dany and John are the three main
characters they all have Targaryen blood
each of their mothers died in childbirth
each of them have had to kill someone
they love each could correspond to one
of the three living dragons with which
they could fulfill the prophecy unites
the Seven Kingdoms and defeat the evil
others and right off for a party on the
Summer Isles for something it seems to
work but does it suit the cynical world
Georgia our Martin has created does the
ridicule to disempowered dwarf have to
turn out to be a magical dragon prince
who saves the day or can he have value
just as a man a prophecies really even a
thing anyway do they magically influence
people's destinies in the Song of Ice
and Fire or do people fulfill them
through their knowledge of them where
several thousand pages in and we've
still never really clearly seen prophecy
at work so the three heads of the Dragon
seemed a shaky reason to believe Tyrion
to be a Targaryen one of the main
reasons why the theory ultimately is
doubtful is that while Tyrion being a
Targaryen bastard does make his awful
relationship with Tywin easier to
understand it makes it something less
Jenna Lannister says that more than
Jaime Tyrion is Tywin's true son Tyrion
has all of tywin's cunning calculating
nature and political skill but in the
form of the dwarf which Tywin so
sensitive to mockery and the appearance
of weakness cannot bring himself to
respect there's so much irony in the
Tyrians drinking and whoring is surely a
consequence of his brutal mistreatment
by his father making him feel worthless
and unloved
but the vices of the Tywin hates Tyrion
for her vices not only that he caused
but that he shares remember Tyrion found
Shae in Tywin's bed before he killed her
which mirrored something Tywin hated his
father Titus for late in life
titles took a common woman as a mistress
and let her steal his dead wife's
jewelry after Titus's death
Tywin punished the woman cruelly running
her naked through the streets of
Lannisport and forcing her to publicly
confessed to being a thief and a harlot
so then late in his own life after the
death of his own wife Tywin sleeps with
the common woman and lets her wear his
jewelry in the hand with the king
necklace what Tywin hates interior is
what he recognizes in himself when Tywin
sits there bleeding out resolutely not
shooting gold and tells Tyrion man
it doesn't mean Tyrion as a secret
Targaryen bastard it means something
much more
it means Tywin has rejected his true
born son refused him and tormented him
because he could not bear to look upon a
twisted version of himself and then
Tyrion murders Thailand with all the
cold brutality of his father
it's tragic it's complex it's the human
heart in conflict with itself
it's what George RR Martin's writing is
really all about not dragon writing and
happy endings
so yes Tyrion has some kind of Targaryen
ish characteristics and yes it's
conceivable that King Aerys old dirty
bastard that he is forced himself on
Joanna and failed that Tyrion but
there's no really strong evidence and it
cheapens one of the most interesting
relationships in the series so for those
reasons it seems possible but quite
unlikely that Tyrion is a Targaryen
thanks for watching this video if you'd
like to see more subscribe or share and
follow on Facebook and Twitter thanks
you